Sean Diddy Combs and Pasi Ventura have
called it quits according to multiple
reports the two were in an on-and-off
relationship for 11 years meeting in the
early 2000s after Cassie was signed to
Diddy's Bad Boy Records label
they were first reported as a couple in
2007 what do you think the key is to
making a relationship work in Hollywood
private - right both have kept their
relationship private when it comes to
the press but in 2016
Cassie told et her do's and don'ts of
love what's one thing a man or a woman
should be doing for the partner I think
you just always and this is just a very
general thing I think you just always
have to remember them if you're going to
you know grab a coffee like do you want
something I think the little things
count more than the big thing sometimes
and I think that's important what's one
thing that they shouldn't do I don't
like like yelling and arguing I'm not
I'm just not I'm very like I like the
coast on a very mellow vibe my
grandparents always said don't go to bed
upset don't go to bed upset that's a
really really good one I think before
you wake up in the morning yeah because
you want you want to wake up like bad
energy that's right absolutely right
exactly so what are the things that you
look for in a perfect match a perfect
match what I look for I really as cheesy
as it sounds I really love a sense of
humor somebody that can make me laugh
all day beats out any look or anything
if we can laugh together that's the the
best thing now do you guys so in
particular in mind when you think about
that quality I think everyone has
somebody
particular in their mind that they think
[Music]